hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play the
amnesia custom story the great work okay
so one of you guys said that there was
some water leaking here that I needed to
get in the glass jar just like that oh
okay
man that would that would not have been
obvious for me I would never got and he
said put out the left candle can I use
his item in his way you sure about that
okay must been the right candle oh and
apparently I do have oil in this lantern
which I somehow overlooked okay
so we're off and one signal me I can Oh
a pot contains wait what what just
happened I thought I didn't know what
wasn't that fall or something I don't
know I don't know either way I'm moving
forward now and good god that music
gah hate that music I hate that music so
much I loaded up the game and oh some
philosophers claim that the history of
this stone can be traced back all the
way to Adam who learned of its existence
when he ate from the tree of knowledge
man I tell you I'm tired of this game
and you know I heard the amnesia music
one on the loading screen oh it's like
oh okay good old AME John
I like amnesia and then I got in the
game and it was like uh it sounds like
something's breathing in the background
oh god I do not like that it's locked
good I don't think I wanted to go in
there anyway I'm gonna run out of oil
real question seriously it sounds like
something [ __ ] breathing oh god it's
so bad do cats not sailors cots I got
the volume turned way up in my
headphones so just try to get more
immersive but I kind of regret that at
this point I mean I'm not joking guys
girls this is the most apprehensive I've
been in an Ambu custom story in a long
time and possible
oh come on let there be oil in here come
on I gotta I gotta conserve gotta
conserve got a concern okay
just stay in the dark just enough to get
by
there's something in there just books
cheer - that is the creepiest on it's
not music so much as it's just
atmosphere it's like something's
breathing and those periods of silence
okay ahahahahahaha thank you oh God
thank you
oh god that is not enough light okay so
we're moving for it I'm gonna try to
creep by without oil I've been um why is
it ready that's something else breathing
and I've got a hammer in chipper maybe
these Canuck these down hook again good
okay so that's locked I'll try to get by
folks I've been raising the brightness
in most of it I got some new software
that's better and I'm raising it not
software but it's a plugin for the
software that I have it's better making
it brighter without overblowing it okay
what's in here what is here what is the
point of all this excuse me why why why
why I ask why why why is his here
why's is here why is this here why do I
feel like I need to be really quiet
seriously this is a most terrified I've
ever been and I mean I mean and I mean
is that where I came in I think this let
me just mark so I have no tinderboxes
left either man they're not no I just
put oil in there
I just put oil in then I just did okay
okay this pitch black I can't see
anything I can't see anything
my eyes aren't adjusting my eyes
adjusting oh I can't see anything oh oh
where am I
I hear you to see you ah God ah get away
get away get hide how the [ __ ] did I get
in here how the [ __ ] do I get here I
can't see anything I can't see anything
oh god okay the play I don't want to
play I don't know play hello ugly
I'm done playing I'm doubling doubling
me out of here get me out of here give
me and her I have no light I've no lamp
you took all my oil
you took my [ __ ] oil I knew something
was wrong ah okay don't go oh god I'll
fight the [ __ ] out of you boy
okay hi so it wasn't in the same oh no
it wasn't in the same room as I was I
was assuming it was just like some
invisible monster that I couldn't see
that was in the same room
I would freaking the [ __ ] out I didn't
realize that it was just kind of across
the way okay so the door is now opening
lordy what's this what is this what is
all this about
ha that that data did dun dah dah dah
Oh God where the [ __ ] is he I can't see
[ __ ]
I can't see anything I can see
absolutely nothing holy crap they're not
giving me anything
I literally the brightness cannot be
this bad I have no oil
they gotta be [ __ ] with me there
gotta be [ __ ] with me this is not
right not right something is not right
here
this isn't normal darkness it's advanced
darkness oh man I'll bring it up for you
guys in post but I'm really flying blind
here and I think they meant it to be
this way because I'm just I'm scraping
through in the dark and I don't even see
a way out of here I just sort of see I'm
trying to I can barely see the outlines
of shapes on the walls and huh nothing
else you guys should be lucky today I
can actually bring this up oh man I
can't see anything what's in here please
let there be oil I need oil so badly a
key a key in a note okay
oil no I know oil in these rooms
oh the breathing is back I have no
dinner boxes second of April 1658 I am
close to completing my final project for
the time being I've locked the golems in
the cells above so that I can continue
my work undisturbed only when my will is
able to enter the shard will I be able
to create the perfect two monk ulis
however I know
longer no if the roars I hear echoing
down the halls real or to say my mind it
has been difficult to maintain my
stability during this process
nevertheless I must proceed before
whatever it is that waits in the
darkness decides to attack it's almost
finished I just need more time
j-mo rain yeah I got the key
wait no wait what that's I touch the key
and it disappeared where did it go no no
there was a key there holy [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] just happened I just there was a
key and then it was gone I didn't even
get a chance to pick it up what the hell
is going on here what the hell is going
on what is that noise see what the
you're messing with me this game is
sticking with me this game is clearly
messing with me there was a key there I
didn't throw it what the [ __ ] is our
noise say something behind here I wish I
could see [ __ ] it you know I'm just
gonna raise the gamma I can't I can't
see [ __ ] I need to be able to see in a
like it's just ridiculous I can't
progress if I can't see I'm gonna miss
something so I brought the gamma for me
hopefully you guys can see to okay
there's nothing behind there what the
[ __ ] happened to that key what was the
key even for that wasn't it wasn't like
there are as locked doors here yeah I'm
so confused something not right here
something is just not right what the
where in [ __ ] did you come from
you weren't there before done now you're
gone
what the [ __ ] what is going on here I
don't even know aah did I do that what
the [ __ ] is happening I'm losing my mom
aah what what what what what what what
what ah there's a knife na are you are
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] ki ah ok ki what the I
don't I don't even know I don't even
know are you do a door over here
wait there's a pathway what is going on
I'm so confused
this game is messing with me and I don't
like it in all honesty I really do like
it because I don't even know where I am
oh wait what damn it I swear it was all
man that was the most subtly my that was
the most subtle mind [ __ ] I've ever seen
in any game I mean things have [ __ ] with
my mind before but that was ridiculous I
mean holy [ __ ] look good God okay I am I
still have no oil they still took my oil
okay so this key goes to some door this
door this door okay
no I'm in here I'm about to lose my mind
okay what is that is that potage
crystallized potage tinderboxes if
that's gonna do me I'm gonna save it I'm
not even gonna do fear I've created a
recipe for an interesting explosive one
of my text refers to as fulminating gold
by soaking a chunk of crystallized
potage in a solution of Eric hydroxide
the resulting crystal becomes highly
reactive if struck it explodes with
great force yet another in my long line
of recent accomplishments a good job
dick
it's in here dumps here Oh Tosh there's
a lot of potage here but I how do I get
to it
hammer it no it's got to be a way to get
this gotta be a way there's plenty of
potage here how do I get to it no it
glows when I'm over it
handle me fight combine it with acid
maybe that would do something no no no
no no no what do I do
the potage is there I just need to
figure out how to interact with it and
holy how I want to get out of here
I do I do I do but I'm not gonna well
I'm tempted to use my one tinderbox on
that crap but I'm not gonna do it I'm
not gonna do it okay there had to be a
reason for coming in here calm down all
right if I just think logically and
throw stuff to the floor I should be
fine yeah okay so I have a note that
explains that I need a sample of
crystallized potage 2 misc with to make
a mix with Eric acid which might may or
may not be that so I need to find a way
to get so now that I know that let me
look around one last time to see if
there's nothing else in one of these
rooms yeah that gnawing is getting to me
I'm guys seriously I got the sound way
turned up I think I think from now on I
tried it as an experiment before but I
think from now on I'm gonna try to UM
make sure that I always play horror
games with the volume way up cuz it's a
lot more immersive ok how do I get into
here I want is that breathing that I
hear in them oh no oh no oh no I haven't
saved oh [ __ ]
ah [ __ ] the game froze balls
dammit alright ah [ __ ] I've been having
lots of problems with that today first
cry of fear and now this I don't know
what the deal is but [ __ ] I didn't say
bye
but Otto saved I really hope it did but
um uh haha oh man
seriously that was one of the best mind
[ __ ] I've ever I've ever I've ever
experienced in my life so it was a good
time I was about time for me to quit
anyway so I'll come back to this later
hopefully I'll be able to get back in
with relative ease so thank you all so
much for watching hope you're enjoying
this because I sure AM if you haven't
already trying for yourself this is
unbelievable and as always just knock
give me a little hint to push me forward
make sure I don't get I don't want to
play an episode where I just get stuck
so if you got a hint for me to move
forward on go ahead and toss it in the
description below or the comments below
so thank you everybody so much for
watching click the annotation for more
videos I've done and as always I will
see you in the next video